just because a candidate can have a
rally with a few thousand people
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
are well-liked Statewide and you know
one of the things we experienced during
the Democratic primary was that if you
based your estimates of support for
Bernie Sanders based on Twitter and
Reddit and I was one of his supporters
you had a much inflated uh sense of
Bernie's support within the Democratic
party and then when voting actually
started taking place you got a very
different sense and we know ultimately
how that went down that all being said
the polls as we reviewed yesterday are
still looking pretty good for Trump in
the Republican primary there was a
period there in early December where Ron
DeSantis was really doing quite well in
the polling but it does appear at least
right now that Donald Trump has a
commanding lead in just about every
Republican primary poll of substance